this is andy from 1995's
toy story showing off a 3d animated
human was a groundbreaking achievement
at the time
but he clearly lacks details when
compared to someone like dash
from 2018's incredibles 2. his freckles
are way more prominent
his long hair is less stiff and his
expressions are more noticeable
humans have always been a challenging
obstacle for pixar
and getting from 1995's andy to where we
are today
took its animators years and countless
simulations to master
all the elements that make up a person
hair skin muscles
and movement
when pixar embarked on its first feature
length film
it still had work to do to figure out
how to make 3d animated human characters
when animators tried some of their
digital models came out stiff
so they came up with some creative
solutions where they could
lighting was one clever way to hide
those imperfections
shrouding human characters in darkness
like in this scene at pizza planet
but in order to avoid showing bodies
completely
they staged many shots so you could only
see feet and hands
like this shot of andy's mom walking in
the room
creating a variety of different people
of all shapes and sizes
and especially the clothes that they
would wear was especially time consuming
so instead of customizing every
individual
they frankensteined it copying body
parts from some
humans and creating new humans out of
those parts
while changing little bits and pieces of
their physical appearance
but even in that first feature film they
did have an early breakthrough
animators needed to distinguish between
the look of the toys
and the look of the humans one way to do
this was through movement
head animator pete doctor observed for
example that woody was floppy and loose
therefore he would have quicker
movements on the other hand
humans were bigger and heavier meaning
they had to slow their movements down
1997's jerry's game was the first pixar
project to feature a human character as
its lead
this four and a half minutes short was
basically an experiment
one of the most prominent features to
focus on for jerry was his skin
human skin needs to be smooth prior to
jerry's game
human models were built in patches skin
sometimes came out looking more plastic
this is where math came to the rescue
enter the subdivision technique
which is when an animator subdivides a
hard-edged
shape enough times that it becomes a
soft and smooth surface
thanks to subdivision jerry's hand looks
much smoother
like a human hand should this method has
been used on
every pixar movie since smoothing out
everything from humans to bugs to
buildings
that work allowed andy and the rest of
the human characters to spend less time
in the shadows in 1999's toy story 2.
another tool that pulled humans out of
the shadows
was a render man shader this let
animators paint on details to the basic
character renderings
like pores veins and blotches there is
no better example of this
advance than toy collector al you can
see the skin imperfections on his face
and even a five o'clock shadow and this
shader tool would be used all the time
it's how they made sure mama coco had
such distinct facial details
compared to other characters in coco but
we didn't see that
until 2017 at the precipice of the new
millennium
pixar was inching closer to giving
animated humans even more screen time
there were still a few hoops to jump
through which you can see
in 2001's monsters inc one of the
biggest
issues with human characters continued
to be their clothes
boo the movie's only human character
wears a big flowy shirt
prior to monsters inc characters wore
clothes that moved automatically with
them
a new simulator called fizz tea enabled
them to animate boo and her shirt
separately
look at how much more natural the
movement of boo's shirt looks
compared to sid's sister's shirt in this
moment from toy story
where the shirt barely moves as she does
and while fizz tea
allowed for both better clothing and all
the fur you see on sully
it couldn't do everything director pete
doctor wanted to give boo
long hair but to do that the animators
would have had to animate in pieces
instead of in one block so to save them
the trouble
they gave her pigtails instead which
were easier to manage
now that pixar could create skin and
make clothes move
it was time to make a feature-length
movie entirely populated by human
characters
in the form of 2004's the incredibles
one of the first tasks conquering long
hair
director brad bird insisted violet have
the long hair
that boo didn't have animators already
had to deal with a lot of hair
collisions on a normal head of hair
so you can imagine how much they dealt
with it for violet
especially with how many different
situations she finds herself in
and all the times she plays with her
hair the team developed a core
simulation engine
that handled all the collisions caused
by long hair
while keeping it moving and flowing as
well as the tools that gave animators
more control
over the placement and velocity of her
hair figuring out how to properly
animate and then render
violet's signature hair took six months
of work
but violet wasn't the only character
pushing the way pixar physically builds
humans
mr incredible is all muscle and none of
pixar's human characters resembled him
for that reason animators used a
software called
goo which allows the skin to react to
moving and sliding muscles
making a character's movement look a lot
more natural
while many of the developments created
for the making of the incredibles were
specific for certain characters
the studio wasn't done perfecting the
look of human skin
see human skin is actually somewhat
transparent
some light needs to go through the skin
scatter around and then reflect back
if the skin looks too solid and no light
gets in
it won't look natural so animators used
subsurface scattering to render skin
with subsurface scattering applied
skin no longer just looked like a rigid
surface
they actually found inspiration for the
skin in an unlikely place
the tools used to make the finding nemo
fish look translucent were used to
scatter light off the skin of humans
here
but with these advancements the studio
never forgot
that the skin couldn't look too
realistic despite the capabilities that
the shader and the subsurface scattering
now allowed
if a human were to look too real then
they would enter into the realm
of the disturbing uncanny valley so
while details like follicles and pores
could have been added
they were purposely left out pixar has
been able to build convincing humans
that don't
follow all the basic rules of human
anatomy throughout the years
for example carl frederickson from
2009's
up his head was deliberately designed to
have
massive boxy proportions and instead of
adding every tiny skin detail
they focused on the most defining
wrinkles in an old man's face
skin and bone aren't the only things
that make up a human
pixar constantly strived to make humans
more expressive
by the time ratatouille was in the works
pixar would have
150 controls just on a character's face
these controls allowed for the varying
movement speeds between
toys and humans in toy story and got
even more sophisticated over the years
granting animators the ability to slow
down and minimize the movements of an
elderly character
like carl and up control points
also allow for the complex expressions
of a character like chef skinner
as well as more subtle and varied body
motions
like linguine's slapstick movements
meanwhile
violet's long hair paved the way for
collette
who had 176 000 30 hairs on her head
advanced simulations had to be applied
to make sure
strands would not merge into each other
despite the sophistication of colette's
hair
pixar still had hair challenges
specifically
mastering curly hair according to
pixar's chief technology officer steve
may curly hair needs to be soft while
still holding a curly
shape so in 2009 simulation supervisor
claudia chung and her team
developed a new simulator called taz for
2012's brave
which built merida's hair as coil-like
locks
to imitate the movement of real curly
hair but the curls would completely
unwind
so the animators added invisible core
springs underneath them
allowing the locks to move with more
control
the better pixar's animators got at
creating humans
the easier it was for them to play
around with their form
and literally deconstruct them 2017's
coco
features a cast of skeleton characters
that were based on humans
animators were able to use the same rigs
they would use for humans covered in
flesh and muscle
but with some changes as the bones
needed to move in ways that you wouldn't
normally see in human characters
for one the skeletons were able to
detach their bones
so the rigs were altered to allow for
this a tool called kingpin
made the bones appear looser by adding
jiggle to them which you can see
here pixar then put all the skin and
muscle back on for incredibles 2
a sequel 14 years in the making
even with all the strides made back in
2004 with the first incredibles
there was still so much more that brad
bird and the animation team
wanted to improve on when the first
movie came out
they didn't have the ability to get
every single detail from the original
clay sculpts of the characters
now they could just look at the
difference between
jack jack in the two movies this is
partially because
for the first time ever pixar was able
to base the character's eyes
off real human eyes sure the eyes are
still bigger and more stylized than
normal
but just look at this shot of dash the
eyes are less circular
and more of an oval when opened wide
meanwhile
creating and rendering violet's long
hair was easier now than it was in 2004
and even more free-flowing here and
speaking of hair
there were further hair breakthroughs in
the past
animators would only be able to work
with scant guide strands of hairs
just guessing what the finalized hair
would look like
that would have made it tough to animate
elastigirl on her motorcycle as her hair
flows in the wind or violet blow drying
her hair
but now animators had full access to
what these characters hair would look
like at every stage of production before
rendering
allowing them to sculpt better
hairstyles and even catch mistakes early
on
another subtle difference between the
two incredibles movies
in incredibles 2 the city streets are
more heavily populated
according to producer nicole paradis
grindel bird thought the urban backdrops
looked too sparse during major moments
crowds are hard as you have to animate
simulate
and render a lot of individual people so
the crowds team
actually started using some motion
capture it was used in coco
on some background skeletons and made
way for better filming of background
humans in incredibles 2.
you can really see just how far human
animation had come
by the time toy story 4 rolled around
just by looking in the background
bonnie's kindergarten class is more
fully realized than the dark pizza
planet
or even andy's birthday party from the
first movie
you can see characters with long hair
and even in this shot from a toys
perspective
all the human faces are clearly seen and
they continued to successfully
experiment with motion capture in order
to populate the film's carnival scenes
what difference does mocap make well
according to toy story 4 crowds lead
neil helm this technology can make human
background characters more convincing
and detailed crowd characters tend to
run
on looping cycles mocap lets filmmakers
capture much longer clips of background
characters carrying out
distinct actions from subdivision
surfaces
to hair bending simulations to
breakthroughs in cloth
and realistic crowds mastering the
elements of human beings
allowed pixar to populate its worlds and
expand the kinds of stories it was able
to tell
and most importantly animators know when
to give characters enough detail that
they seem
human but enough exaggeration in their
form
that they're still part of an animated
universe
pixar's next chance to show us all the
hard work it does on human characters
the upcoming soul
hi thanks so much for watching if you'd
like to see more videos just like this
one
remember to hit the subscribe button
what other aspects of pixar's animation
process do you want to learn more about
let us know in the comments